[Music]
you have so many intimate scenes on the
show with Michael Sheen he is here not
too long ago and I'm just curious you're
professionals you're actors but the
first time that you do that isn't that a
nerve-racking experience yes yes I mean
was it for you too well there were some
really nice brownies on set it went
perfectly yeah great but I'm just
curious it was weird it was very I mean
the first season the first time that I
take my clothes off with Michael Sheen
it's a scene in the first season where
we're getting all hopped up on science
talk and we're excited about science and
this the science of sex which is what
our show is about it about masters in
Johnson and during this scene I'm
supposed to unbutton my blouse and
remove my brassiere and then take
Michael's hand and place it upon my
breast now I'm mesmerized I know the
scene but I like hearing you talk about
well thank you
and yeah so it was I was scared mainly
because he was my friend at that point
and I mean I I don't generally conduct
myself in that way with my friends
generally and enemies only hate you yeah
well anyway he's very professional I
fancy myself as somebody you know who
can be professional and so I thought
it's gonna be fine it's gonna be fine
this is it's a pivotal scene it works
for the show it's necessary so we're
doing the scene things are going fine I
begin the unbuttoning of the blouse I'm
noticing that I'm very nervous and my
hands are kind of shaking and and and
then I grab his hand and I noticed that
his hands are shaking and a little
clammy and he looks bad and nervous and
shaky and so that's kind of making me
feel better and we complete scene I
placed the hand on my breast and they
all cut and he immediately walks over to
a garbage can and throws up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yes and what's going on there well I
later found out that he had food
poisoning but in the moments
there's no way to digest that in a
reasonable way you didn't know that I
thought it was a direct cause-and-effect
my whole self confidence plummeted to
the ground yeah and I realized that I'm
a monster and anybody who touches me
will immediately start vomiting I'm
sorry to laugh at must been horrible but
it's hilarious
yeah yeah it was a bit traumatic for him
yeah I think I handled it pretty I think
you did
you